une habile presque millénaire depuis mai
68 c'est ici qu'en lieu tous les
courants demandé roi d'angleterre
[Applaudissements]
un lieu hautement symbolique pour les
funérailles d'elizabeth 2 dont le règne
a été le plus long de l'histoire
britannique
le cercueil est entrée suivis d arrière
petit enfant de la reine au cours de
cette cérémonie la famille royale a
évidemment occuper une place centrale
mais parmi les 2000 invités dans
l'abbaye on comptait aussi des
représentants d'autres monarchies et des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement venus
des quatre coins du monde pendant son
long règne elizabeth ii a vu se succéder
15 premier ministre britannique quatorze
présidents américains et 12 premiers
ministres canadiens
la reine avait déclaré que sa vie serait
consacrée au service de la nation et du
commonwealth
a mais une telle promesse n'aura été
aussi bien tenu a souligné l'archevêque
de canterbury
[Musique]
cérémonie des chants religieux et de la
cornemuse qui a fait résonner le
musicien qui en jouait tous les jours
pour la souveraine
[Musique]
puis un longue hommage sans bruit
deux minutes de silence qui ont été
respectées biên au delà de l'abbaye
norail park immense espace vert au coeur
de la capitale des dizaines de milliers
de personnes ont suivi les funérailles
d'état sur des écrans géants des
londoniens mais aussi des britanniques
venus d'un peu partout au pays juliette
est claire deux soeurs se sont retrouvés
ici pour la cérémonie
le nom vient de newcastle l'autre de
manchester il a fallu des heures de
déplacement pour rejoindre ce
rassemblement
sans grande monarchiste elle affirme
avoir voulu rendre hommage à une femme
qui a consacré sa vie à servir le pays
m6 bénin elle a été là toute ma vie
c'est quelqu'un qui nous tenons pour
acquis lance-t-elle ému
beaucoup de britanniques ont profité de
ce jour férié pour se recueillir faire
une pause sachant bien qu'une fois le
déterminer les enjeux comme l'inflation
et la crise énergétique s'imposeront de
nouveau dans l'actualité
la vie continuera mais nous ne
l'oublierons pas dit elle
[Musique]
une fois la cérémonie à l'abbaye
terminée la dépouille de la reine a
entrepris son dernier voyage au coeur de
la capitale un parcours réglé au quart
de tour avec un passage devant le palais
de buckingham
[Musique]
mais la destination finale est un autre
château celui de windsor qui pendant la
pandémie est devenue la résidence
principale de la reine
[Musique]
c'est dans cette chapelle qui est
d'isabelle 2 a été inhumé près de son
mari sa soeur sa mère et son père une
ultime cérémonie qui marque
officiellement la fin d'un chapitre de
l'histoire